tango is the largest vc here in israel
managing more than two billion dollars
uh within two billion two billion yeah
the asset management
[Music]
sapir thank you so much for joining me
on 20-minute leaders
thank you for having me so great to have
you so you're in the pitango offices now
right
yeah that's right no it's a virtual
background
yeah it looks like that yeah it's about
10 p.m in israel all the time right now
so that makes perfect sense
uh i've been following pitango for a
long time i've been following you for a
long time
you know as we were preparing for this
for this conversation i was actually
looking
and i saw that we actually communicated
quite a few times
over the past few years mainly when i
requested for you to let me come to one
of your conferences or one of your
events
so uh i i think you led me into some of
them so
thank you
tell me a little bit about who you are
because you have a really interesting
background and i'm really excited for
this
sure um so now i work at the tango
venture capital as an associate
i'm a part of the early stage team i
will explain more about the venture
after that
i'm also a board member of the 8200
alumni association
and the managing director of the 8200
yang forum
which we know each other from there yep
okay so tell me just in a few words for
context 8200 is one of the the idf's
leading
uh technological units and it is
probably the equivalent
of of mit or stanford in terms of
computer science and tech background in
terms of colleges
and you are you served in that unit but
you also took a very active community
role
in helping organize those that are that
are released
right so talk to me a little bit about
that sure
so um when i came back from the u.s
after two years um
i was a procurement manager uh in the
ministry of defense there
i came back and i had a lot of questions
about my future like
where i'm going to study what exactly i
wanted to do in the future
i do know exactly as mit it's a good
example
for a community there's a community of
the graduates but in 8200 there was no
such a thing like that
we had some events of legacy events
about you know like uh
very old stuff um and not something for
the younger generation
until then so i thought that it could be
great
to have all of those you know young
generation of 8200 and
gather uh into one group and to help
each other of course
but also for the whole community um so
we started it uh
just you know like a crazy idea uh with
some friends from the unit
and uh we started with a small event we
thought that it will be a small event
of um sorry um
of uh the young you know like the new uh
graduates uh from the unit and uh
we we're trying to answer those
questions about like um
if you did a specific course what you're
going to do with that
after the army and right some stories of
graduates
and we thought that we would have only
you know like 50 people
but we had full hours of 250
graduates yeah it was amazing um
and then we understood that there is a
need for that community
um you know it's like a product you have
to to check before you do something and
that's where we started to do more uh
so we had like exclusive events with all
the keynote speakers uh here in the
ecosystem from you know like ceos
of companies uh journalists a lot of
great stories
after that we added some workshops for
the graduates
like linkedin workshop how to you know
to present myself
other many fields of you know like how
to uh
promote myself um we had some hackathons
i think you took
uh yeah in the machine in one of the
machine learning hackathons yeah correct
yes so we had some academes uh we added
more uh
courses of like machine learning course
uh to
teach the basics of uh machine learning
like
to have no superior i think that's i
think i think it's incredible because
you know having gone through that
experience on one hand
it's almost like the same a similar
bubble to any
very strong community that you're part
of and i'm comparing that right now to
my experience let's say at stanford
you're growing up with this community
everything is fantastic inside you get
to know the ins and outs of the
of the base and the people and the
workforce and then you finish
and you go out to the to the world and
while you have very strong background
sometimes you have a lot of skill sets
you have no idea how to use them and you
don't know wow exactly
like where do i go from here what am i
worth how do i present to myself how can
i even talk about what i did
and it's and it's what you did yeah yeah
so you had you had such a strong do you
know how many people went through
these events or or what is how what is
the community now like
yeah so we have like uh you know like uh
3 000 graduates right now in the group
and it
keeps growing every time um yeah
in each event we have like between 100
to
200 people um it's yeah it's amazing and
we have like two events in a month
and a lot of uh new programs like
mentoring and internships
great yeah really wonderful so and and i
think that the best thing about it's up
here
is that now you've you've moved on to
other things but you're still so
connected to this baby of yours that you
started
and you get to have that personal
satisfaction of seeing it grow
and prosper even as other people are
helping lead it
let's move on to pitango because you
mentioned that you have a really
interesting
way of interesting strategy of
investment the 40s
what are the four t's great um
so every company that we see at pitango
uh
maybe i'll explain a bit about pitango
pitango is the largest
vc here in israel managing more than two
billion dollars
uh within two billion two billion yeah
the asset under management yeah
okay we invested in more than 250
companies
yeah we exist more than 27 years when
family and
family and ramesh founded the company
like the fun um and actually three years
ago we
restructured the fund instead of one
fund that is focused
on many fields and many stages we
separated it to
three funds so we have the growth fund
that is more focused
on you know like um companies that reach
to
the product market fit and have some
significant revenues
the second one is the health tech
investing in
companies like digital health and
medical devices
and the third one uh which i think that
is the most exciting
because i'm a part of it's the early
stage
fund we do some really interesting
investments like
seed investments and a rounds uh we help
companies to build their own company
from the beginning like from the idea
we do the brainstorming yes yes that's
not so uh unknown i think that's not so
known outside but we do some really
interesting investments from the
beginning
um and we we invest in
like deep tech technologies and strong
teams
also from our units but of course
outside the
in the 8200 family um so we have the
strategy yeah 40s
uh the credit is uh it's not for me it's
uh for a young
is one of our managing partners but i
think that's this very unique um
uh method because you can actually um
learn a lot of that from you know like
um an entrepreneur about
what you're going to do uh in the pitch
so the first one
is the team of course we said four t's
so the first one is the team
uh we think it's the most important part
of
of you know like a startup um so we want
to know about your background your
experience
how did you meet each other um the
synergy between the founders
seriously we are like 70 psychologists
and 30
financial investors so i love it be
ready for that yeah
i love it i was talking to i was
actually talking to
giggy levy just the other day and
and he also i mean 70 people
20 percent field to 10 ideas yeah
that's right um so the second thing is
the theme like the market size
is it a big opportunity um we want to
see there
uh that the startups are very aware to
their
competitors like show us the whole
picture of your competitors
explain how you differentiate yourself
from others
you know like many times we see that
startups are afraid from competition
because they think like
oh when now they see that there is a
competition they
might think to not invest there but it's
so
uh different because we when we see a
competition we see a need we see a
market
and uh just we want to know that uh they
are aware for that
um i have to have to stop you there and
ask you have you ever encountered an
entrepreneur
that that you asked them what's your
competition and they said
i'm competing with them google aws and
microsoft
no way no no no no but they said yeah
we're competing with them
and there's no differentiation we're
just gonna win have you ever heard that
because
it's so rare yeah
yeah we've seen a lot of um very
very weird things of course we're better
than them we have
like a better skill set than they have
but
i actually value that sometimes because
you know sometimes when people don't
acknowledge that they have direct
competitors
who with very little differentiation
that's also a very big red flag
because especially in a lot of the
congested markets
at the saturated segments it's very hard
sometimes to find this really unique
differentiation that's right
and right now you're talking to a vc but
what will be
when you will talk with a customer when
he uses
something else yeah so that's totally
right and
i think that it's also a maturity to
understand that there is a competition
but
how you differentiate yourself from
others that's fine um
the third thing or the third t is the
technology
of course uh like i mentioned we invest
in deep technology
so we want to make sure that you have a
unique approach
that is going to be a barrier for other
uh startups that
will yeah will be in the same space so
be prepared
uh with the pitch of course uh to to be
focused on that
i think that um you know right now um
a lot of early stage pcs uh have
some like ours uh like tech
guys that can actually evaluate the
technology and validate
girls yeah and orgers of course
you're a software engineer of course
yeah i'm saying like guys but of course
there are some uh very strong women also
i mean you're a perfect example of that
you're coming from
yeah yeah so uh i think that
at that point i i would say that it's
very important to do your own dd on us
on the vc who is going to meet you
because you know like if if i'm a
software engineer
i probably would like to know more about
your
specific technology so it's very
important to
to be prepared for that and to bring
your cto
i had a lot of meetings with like when
i'm going to the technology they said oh
uh maybe you should
meet the cto or the vprnd or the
outsource
outsourcing company that we no it's not
like that
it's very important for us um and the
fourth thing uh it's the terms of the of
the deal of course like
how much you're going to raise but not
only um you know like the number
it's more like where the money will take
you how many customers how many uh like
the attraction
um show us your business uh model like
your roadmap it's so important because i
i think that right now we have so many
uh seed
seed stages uh deals that are very very
you know like uh
for five or uh even above
million dollars and just explain us what
what are you going to do with the money
not just because it's common to take uh
that amount of money let us know that uh
exactly what you're gonna do with that
yeah no that's definitely and i think
that's
i know and it makes a lot of sense
especially you know i think it's also a
very big sign of maturity among
among entrepreneurs and i hope to be
able to exert a similar maturity
when one day i do get to to find my to
find my own startup and
of course you'll be the first phone call
that i make to pitch to you
but but yeah knowing how much you're
raising what are you raising for
am i raising because i have a big ego
and i need to show the world that i'm
good
or am i raising because i actually need
to fulfill a burn rate for the next
16 months so that i can raise my next
round i i completely agree and i and i
think
and i personally think it's also a very
important role of the investors and the
current investors
to be there for the founders and say
okay you know this is a partnership
we're not going against each other
this is like let's work together on
evaluation and on a round
that would make sense strategically as
we're positioned to go for our a
b and c because this is the same stage
we're just starting out this is a
partnership
in the long run we're gonna have to go
through a lot of hurdles together
that's right i think they don't think
about the next round
they just think about you know like the
current situation and they want to raise
uh yeah sometimes and yeah it's about
maturity of course
sapir very very you know you're you're a
software engineer by profession
for a lot of time he transitioned to
more of the community role and then an
investment role
what was that transition like what made
you do that transition
wow um so i think like um i'm
very in love with tech of course
i love to uh to do the programming work
and i love to work
of course uh at rafael and after that uh
a few startups but
it's uh a main part of me but also um i
have the part of um
working with people of course like
people personally yeah i'm a people
person of course and um
the other part which i met uh
recently i think in my last position at
uh cloucher
was to understand the whole picture how
uh
the sales and marketing works how um
who are our customers i want to know
everything but why should i know that
i'm just a developer i just need to
develop
my own features and that's it so when
you see the triangle between like
tech people and to be impactful and to
see the whole picture
you have only two choices for you know
like for
your next job it's whether to be an
entrepreneur or
to be a venture capitalist um so i
decided to go to the dark side of course
uh i thought that it's a bit too early
for me to
um jump into the water of the
you know like all these journey and
and it's amazing of course the community
was also part of me
to impact others and to do some you know
like big things together i think that
of course in 8200 i had a big
opportunity
to do on my own great things and it
opened my eyes also
of course like you can do some amazing
things only with an idea i think all of
the great programs that i mentioned just
became an idea
when we meet for coffee with friends and
after a few months it was a program with
sponsorships and everything
was amazing yeah it's like a startup of
course yeah
and where are you yeah are you
in some way gearing for a first startup
one day or is that is that something
that you're thinking about or
are you sort of letting it letting it
right out wherever it goes
so i had like a good answer for that
um one year ago when i thought that
i would join a vc only for two years and
then i will move on to
my entrepreneurship road
and right now it's not so clear for me
because you know you you're not so naive
as you you've been one year before and i
think it's very important to
of course you you start to feel the
how how bad is to be an entrepreneur
seriously how bad and how difficult it
is
and to be on the other side of the table
it's
it's great of course and you can help
them to do the
hard work but it's i think for
for now i i love to sit um
on boards and to be a venture capitalist
and no no you're not superior
and obviously you have the privilege of
being in one of the best vc's not only
but in the world with the incredible
jami perez and some other friends that
we talked about
before that before we started recording
this uh so definitely i mean
it sounds like it's also such a great
learning opportunity to being able to
see so many different areas
become very quickly and intelligent
discussion at the discussion maker in
those areas and be able to
have some personal insights i think
that's just wonderful uh
where what what is your even within
pitango what are you really excited
about
this are there specific industries or
are really agnostic
um so we invest really agnostic of
course
but you know my own yeah
what i like the most of course it's dev
tools and everything about developers
because i believe that developers can
actually impact others and to bring
some value to the whole company um
so i totally in love with companies and
the space of devtools and devops
and we did some great investments there
um
also i think like you're in love with
other fields like
sales and marketing that's the i think
that's the
bread and butter in the vc that you have
so many
uh different fields that you can just
dig into that
and to learn a lot of that and to be in
love with that
we just did two investments in quantum
computing
seriously i didn't understand the word
before that and now i can
talk not enough yeah but
just talk about quantum it's amazing
yeah it's amazing
i love it it's up here before we end and
again thank you for spending the time to
do this i
really appreciate it i need three words
that
you would best describe yourself who is
sapir
so i would say uh passionate about
everything i'm doing
seriously i'm in love with everything uh
persistent maybe
yeah and uh ambitious i love it
all right passionate persistent and
ambitious yeah i think i think that
that's really what it takes it's a peer
to dog thank you so much thank you so
much for having me best of luck thank
you very great time
i'm looking forward to a coffee back in
israel where we're in the same we're in
the same country
that's for sure bye thanks
you